peut-être quelques mots du contexte
d'abord au terme de ces quatre ans et
demi de négociations
j'essaie d'utiliser toutes les
tempéraments de montagnards qui est le
mien d'un habitué aux longues marches
votre calme
persévérant respectueux et ne pas mettre
dans cette négociation d'émotion ou de
passion j'ai capable de parler de
l'europe et de nettoiement de notre pays
avec passion mais s'agissant de cette
négociation l'objectif était clairement
de d'être respectueux et de ne pas de
s'en tenir aux faits aux chiffres on
base légale et aux intérêts de l'union
européenne mais tout de même il s'agit
d'une négociation extraordinaire unique
j'espère qu'elle le restera celle liée à
un pays qui a choisi volontairement
démocratiquement de quitter l'union
européenne c'est la première fois
ce qui prouve d'ailleurs au passage que
l'union européenne n'est pas une prison
qu'on veut la quitter si on accepte
d'assumer les conséquences et ses
responsabilités c'est un divorce dont
nous parlons
comme tout divorce je pas d'expérience
personnelle mais beaucoup de mes amis en
ont donc je peux constater que c'est un
divorce qui provoque comme toujours un
divorce des conséquences graves
nombreuses conséquences sociales
humaines économiques financières
techniques juridiques innombrables
souvent sous-estimé généralement mal
expliqué et je n'ai cessé de dire depuis
le premier jour de cette mission je me
souviens de la première conférence de
presse en décembre 2016 à bruxelles que
ses conséquences la a été généralement
sous-estimé qu'est ce qu'on a fait
face à un divorce qui provoque tente de
conséquences et d'insécurité juridique
pour tellement de monde et citoyens les
entreprises les états nous avons essayé
de remettre de la certitude là où le
divorce le président crée de
l'incertitude
nous l'avons fait en deux étapes pour
traiter d'abord la question du divorce
politique et institutionnel fait de
quitter l'union européenne et dans un
deuxième temps celui dont une part est
jean-françois l'instant le divorce le
président économique et commerciale et
ses séquences sequencing monde iront en
patois savoyard est extrêmement
important nous avons voulu traiter
d'abord la question du divorce
institutionnels et tous les problèmes
qu'il crée et puis ensuite nous avons
ouvert une deuxième négociation courtes
comme vous l'avez dit madame la
présidente
prima sur le commerce l'économie
la future relation dans la première
négociation je le rappelle parce que
nous sommes toujours sur la base de ce
traité dans son application
[Musique]
côté de 1200 pages qui a traité la
question des citoyens ça concerne
beaucoup de personnes que vous
connaissez sans doute autour de vous
quatre millions et demi de personnes 1,3
million et demi de européen qui vit au
royaume uni un million et demi de
britanniques qui vivent chez nous pour
lesquelles on a garanti pour chacun pour
chacune de leurs familles pour la durée
de leur vie la totalité des droits
sociaux et les droits de résidence
acquis par eux jusqu'à la fin de l'année
dernière 4 millions et demi de personnes
voient sécuriser leurs droits je parle
bien des droits acquis c'est une autre
question que celle des gens qui vont
maintenant aller au royaume uni où venir
chez nous
auxquels seront appliquées notamment du
côté du royaume uni la politique
extrêmement différentes d'immigration
très différentes de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui était jusqu'à maintenant la
liberté de circulation
on a traité la question du budget le
budget c'est beaucoup d'argent
la clé c'est que les britanniques ont
accepté dans ce premier traité de payer
à 28 tout ce qui a été décidé à 28
ça concerne la pac ça concerne la
politicaillerie le petit fonds
structurels la recherche tout ce qui
était décidé à 28 a été et a été ou sera
pays à 28 et enfin ça concerne la
question que tu évoquais l'instant
irlande
la question la plus sensible personne
n'a jamais été capable chers collègues
de me démontrer la moindre valeur
ajoutée du breakbeat personne pas même
monsieur marage mais là où vous pouvez
constater que le brésil a le plus de
conséquences et de risques
c'est l'irlande et ça ne concerne pas
d'abord les marchandises le commerce la
technique ça concerne les hommes et les
femmes la paix dans une île où s'est
déroulé un conflit entre plusieurs
communautés qui a provoqué quatre mille
morts 4 et cette paix est fragile et 7
pl est lié un accord qu'on appelle le
good friday agreements signé une
vingtaine d'années au terme duquel une
des conditions de 7 pc qui est pas de
frontières du tout donc vous êtes je
répète ici je lui ai déjà dit en irlande
du nord royaume-uni
vous traversez cet hémicycle et vous
êtes au bout là on y rendent aux
républicains dans le marché unique
le problème c'est que la limite du
marché unique elle est là et que nous
devons à toutes les frontières toutes
les limites extérieures du marché unique
nous devons aux consommateurs aux
budgets nationaux et aux entreprises un
contrôle de toutes les marchandises qui
passe la ligne contrôle sanitaire
vétérinaire alimentaire sécuritaire
contrôles pour les taxes éventuels qu'on
perçoit peau ou la tva pour le budget
national du pays ou pour la budget
européen contrô le et des produits
industriels pour lutter contre la
contrefaçon
ça c'est la règle générale et d'autres
questions sophie de savoir si ces
contrôles se sont fait correctement ou
pas mais ils sont faits et on les doit
au marché unique aux gens qui
travaillent qui habite d'un marché
unique
donc le problème nous en a eu et
résoudre en irlande était prêt et très
compliqué nous avons cherché des
solutions opérationnelles concrètes aux
problèmes que pose et le bric site et en
irlande c'est pas autre chose le brésil
qui crée le problème
donc on a cherché les solutions nous les
avons trouvés après deux ans de négocier
sur le theresa may finalement avec son
successeur boris johnson et aux termes
de cet accord qui date d'un an et d'un
peu plus d'un an qu'il faut appliquer
territoire d'irlande du nord fait partie
en quelque sorte du marché unique
il reste intègre un douanier britannique
les contrôles se font non pas sur l'île
puisqu'on peut pas les faire
physiquement sur l'île ils se font à la
frontière à la limite de l'île aussi
bien à dublin en république d'irlande ça
c'est pas un problème puisque c'est
l'union européenne qu'à belfast juste de
rappeler les abysses où les sénateurs
qu'une vache qui rentrent en irlande du
nord à belfast venant d'angleterre du
même pays
cette vache rentrer en france elle
remporte belgique il rentre en allemagne
mécaniquement puisque n'y a pas de
frontières et rentrer dans le marché
unique donc nous devons la contrôler
elle sera donc comprenez à belfast et un
britannique ont accepté que ces
contrôles soient effectués par leurs
autorités leur service avec notre
coopération et nous avons une dizaine de
vétérinaires d'agents des douanes qui
coopèrent déjà depuis le 1er janvier
cette situation est complexe et parce
que parce que la situation en irlande et
complexe le protocole est complexe mais
il est opérationnel et durable et donc
toutes vont en dédramatisant en évitant
de mettre de la passion de lit
au logis prouver à le faire fonctionner
de manière opérationnelle
je dis juste un mot de ce qui s'est
passé il ya quinze jours
dans le contexte de la lutte anti
qu'ovide de cette campagne de
vaccination des difficultés que nous
avons rencontrées en europe
la commission a voulu établir un
contrôle des exportations de vaccins
n'ont pas d'interdiction mais de savoir
qui exportent quoi et où
et dans ce souci de contrôler et de
savoir qu'ils exportent quoi ue a été
activé et c'était une erreur
jusqu'aux articles 16 qui prévoient de
nouveaux contrôles en irlande alors même
que je m'étais battu pendant cinq ans
pour qu'il ait pas de frontières donc
donc c'était une erreur
je vais pas revenir là-dessus la
présidente de la commission l'a reconnu
et murs corrigé immédiatement trois
heures après voilà je vais pas dire
autre chose mais nous n'avons pas nous
voulons pas qu'il y ait de contrôle et
de frontières au sein de l'irlande et
nous voulons dédramatiser les contrôles
que les britanniques ont accepté de
faire pour préserver les conditions de
cette paix et en même temps garantir la
sincérité du marché unique
plusieurs jeudi c'est un peu une
quadrature du cercle que nous avons
aussi de résoudre voilà pour l'accord de
retrait je le dis parce qu'il reste là
et pour répondre à une question qui a
été posée je crois la présidente par
vous
cet accord là comme le nouvel accord
dont je vais dire un mot seront suivis
par deux services de la commission open
deux unités l'une pour l'accord de
retrait l'une pour le nouvel accord qui
constitueront une direction sous
l'autorité de la présidente et ses deux
deux services seront mis en place le 1er
mars prochain
issu de la task force que j'ai animé
pendant quatre ans et qui va être
dissoute
le nouvel accord qui concerne la future
relations économiques et commerciales
notamment
nous avons eu neuf mois pour le négocier
comme vous l'avez dit c'était unique
l'accord pour le japon a exigé six ans
l'accord avec le canada 5 ans et demi
donc jamais nous n'avons négocié un
accord de commerce
l'accord de libre-échange dans un délai
aussi court
ce qui explique pourquoi nous avons mis
sur la table dès le début une
proposition que nous ne l'avions jamais
mieux d'emblée sur la table d'un
partenaire tiers pas tarifs et pas de
copains si on avait lu des gosses y est
les tarifs ligne par ligne ou produit
par produit il aurait fallu cinq ou six
ans est le seul moyen d'éviter ce que
vous avez appelé un proxy sec ou dur
c'était clairement de dire aura pas de
quotas et pas de tarif très bien mais
avec un pays qui se trouve là où ils se
trouvent
qui entend le rester durablement à côté
de nou 0 km entre l'irlande et le
royaume uni entre le marché unique et 0
km et avec lequel nous avons des
échanges majeur important dé exportant à
peu près 8 % vers le royaume uni et il
exporte 40 6%
le tout c'est cela qui passe rapidement
je voudrais qu'on montre la faille si
c'est possible d'aider avec les bulles
on peut le cgp à la voilà
ce style là que vous connaissez
peut-être elle est très significative
elle montre sur deux axes la proximité
géographique de nos partenaires dans le
monde et l'importance et le volume de
chaque rond de nos échanges
qu'est ce qu'on voit ses recettes side
que le royaume uni en rouge est dans une
position unique passe à proximité zéro
kilomètre et par le volume des échanges
le plus important par rapport à tout ce
qui se trouve à droite ce sont le canada
la corée du sud et d'autres et puis sur
la première ligne c'est celui sous ou la
norvège qui ont d'ailleurs des rapports
différents la norvège et les demandes du
marché unique mais pas de l'union
la suisse a dit d'accord très
particulier donc on a dû faire attention
parce que c'est la première fois chers
collègues qu'on négocie un accord de
libre échange dans un contexte de
divergence réglementaires et non pas de
convergence la première fois de notre
histoire
il s'agit donc pas de d'encourager la
convergence comme on l'a fait avec le
japon le canada avec des normes et des
standards pour commercer plus facilement
s'agit d'empêcher que la divergence que
les britanniques ont voulu c'est le
coeur même du bric site
cette autonomie législative et
réglementaire ne devienne l'outil de
dumping comme tu l'as dit tout et c'est
ça qui a rendu la négociation difficile
parce que les britanniques naturellement
avait l'idée de bénéficier des avantages
du marché unique et sans être contraint
par les règles et le pouvoir comme
certains l'ont dit créé je ne sais quel
singapour sur tamise
il n'en est pas question donc on a
imposé dans cette négociation et nous le
ferons désormais dans tous nos nouveaux
accords commerciaux des règles du jeu
équitables
je le dis en français pour ne pas le
dire en anglais on a conclu en disant
level playing field que le commerce a
ouvert libre nous n'avons pas peu peur
nous ne craignons pas la concurrence
je fais partie de la vie la concurrence
contre nous
partout dans l'économie il faut que
cette concurrence soit le plus loyal
possible et est donc nous avons créé
dans cet accord des outils de dissuasion
de prévention qui pour deux sujets
l'attribution des aides d'état et la non
régression des standards et des normes
s'il y avait des divergences sur ces
deux sujets aides d'état massif sur un
secteur économique et nous savons que ça
va se produire
créant des destructions d'emplois de
notre côté ou des divergences
réglementaire qui donne à l'un par
rapport à l'autre une compétitivité
indus nous avons la capacité de mettre
en place des mesures compensatoires de
rétablir des tarifs de faire des
suspensions croisées avec d'autres
secteurs de l'accord voire de remettre
tout en cause et tous les quatre ans il
y aura une évaluation une mise à plat de
l'accord pour voir son fonctionnement
voilà je peux pas dire que tout ça va
marcher parfaitement et je suis d'accord
avec vous tous les trois que dans un
accord pour moi je je pensais qu'un
gouvernement juste devaient attacher
autant d'importance aux effets de suivi
cause effet d'annonce de c'est toujours
la conviction
lorsque j'étais ministre j'ai toujours
eu ce souci de vérifier le suivi et
l'application
nous sommes exactement dans ce cas il
faudra être très vigilant et votre
parlement national sénat en particulier
devront participer à travers ses
commissions à ce travail de contrôle et
d'évaluation et que les autorités
françaises veiller à ce que cette
évaluation se fasse correctement mais
nous avons des outils et les experts la
commission considère que le cadre est
compliqué mais crédible et fonctionnel
ça c'est la première partie de l'accord
commerce
le deuxième partie c'est l'économie
d'autres partenariats économiques pour
en particulier l'énergie
l'interconnectivité électrique
les coopérations mer du nord transport
transport routier sabotage transport
aérien certaines libertés et la pêche
peut-être plusieurs un mot de la pêche
parce que c'était le sujet jusqu'au bout
le plus compliqué il se trouve que j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être le ministre des
pêcheurs français
je sais la difficulté de ce métier son
danger
j'ai du respect infini pour les pêcheurs
et donc je je me suis attaché à cette
question comme d'ailleurs les 27 états
membres qui ont été solidaires pour les
tous n'étaient pas également concernés
mais il y en avait 11 qui était concerné
8 plus directement dont la france et les
positions de départ dans cette
négociation était très différente
les britanniques voulaient tous
récupérés ils pouvaient le faire en cas
de désaccord nous pêchons dans les eaux
britanniques 650 millions d'euros par an
nous les pêcheurs européens
ils pêchent dans leurs eaux 850 millions
et dans nos eaux 150 mais il pouvait
récupérer les 650 millions et nous
sommes partis en disant on ne change
rien alors naturellement c'était
difficile de tenir cette position
puisqu'ils quittait le marché unique et
il quitte la politique commune des
pêches
il retrouve la souveraineté sur leur
zone donc il pouvait nous exclure le
résultat des courses ou de la
négociation c'est que nous rendrons dans
le temps durablement et notamment dans
les cinq ans qui viennent les sept
continuera après nous rendrons 25% de
nos opportunités de pêche alors qu'ils
me demandaient 100 % voilà l'accord qui
était fait
et puis il ya de stabilité de cinq ans
et demi j'avais proposé six ans au terme
de laquelle il y aura des négociations
annuelles
et là aussi nous avons prévu dans
l'accord de pêche des mesures de
compensation ou de répliques pour
protéger nos activités si jamais les
britanniques prenait des mesures très
brutale de fermeture d'une partie de la
totalité de la mer du nord par exemple
qui provoquait des problèmes très graves
nous avons une mesure de répliques
interne au secteur de la pêche et
croisée je veux par exemple précisé que
j'ai introduit dans la négociation une
mesure miroir de ce qui est prévu dans
la pêche dans le secteur de l'énergie
en d'autres termes l'interconnectivité
électrique est économiquement très
importante pour les britanniques et qui
est économiquement pour eux est établi
pour cinq ans et demi exactement comme
pour la pêche et tous les ans ensuite y
aura une discussion annuelle pour
maintenir ou pas l'interconnectivité
électrique des britanniques ont marché
électrique européen
voilà une mesure miroir je pense qu'ils
ont compris de quoi il s'agissait
le dans le domaine de la coopération
comique on a aussi de l'ouverture des
programmes européens
on a proposé comme aux autres pays tiers
norvège la suisse israël israël
participer dans d'autres conditions
qu'aujourd'hui au prime de recherche
promet spatiaux à erasmus
ils ont refusé de participer à ce mu
parce qu'ils veulent créer un port en
parallèle et concurrents mais ils
participeront prendre de recherche qui
est notamment un je crois utile et
intelligent de deux côtes et troisième
secteurs de coopération établie dans cet
accord la sécurité intérieure et donc
après qu'ils aient accepté de respecter
les grands principes de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui est
acceptée ce que nous demandions pour le
contrôle des données personnelles dans
le cadre des règles que nous appliquons
en europe
nous avons trouvé des moyens
opérationnels qu'il participe à europol
eurojust extradition elle lutte contre
le blanchiment de l'argent
le programme prime qui prévoit l'échangé
des données adn très personnel et puis
les programmes liés aux protection des
passagers le 1er la voilà troisième
grand chapiteau 4ème chapitre concerne
la gouvernance il y aura un accord cadre
global et à l'intérieur du paquet
économique
un seul système de règlement des
conflits et cette suspension croisé à
laquelle nous tenions il pendant
plusieurs mois la bataille était très
dur parce qu'il voulait faire du
saucissonnage à la suisse je puis
permettront du salami salami n'est pas
un produit suisse
donc on a voulu nous tenir ses leçons
des précédents accords et avoir un
accord global
voilà ce qui est dans l'accord et chers
collègues dames et messieurs les
sénateurs qui n'est pas soumis à la
négociation
c'est terminé il s'agit d'appliquer il
n'y aura pas de négociations sur tous
ces sujets en revanche il ya deux sujets
qui n'ont pas été dans la négociation
l'un parce que nous ne voulions pas et
l'autre parce qu'il ne le voulait pas
celui dont nous ne voulions pas dans les
négociations c'est celui que tu as
évoqué jean françois et services
financiers
on ne négocie pas des équivalences
financière entre eux nous allons
attribuer certains activement financière
dit nous la commission et dans le cas de
l'union attribuera comme nous l'avons
fait avec le japon ou les états unis d
équivalence à certains
industrie financière certains services a
peut être les auditeurs par exemple où
les agences de notation peut être
d'autres en fonction de nos intérêts et
en tenant compte d'une règle majeure
majeur si on n'a pas la mémoire quand
décès de notre stabilité financière nous
ne prendrons pas de risque du point de
vue la supervision et de la régulation
mais nous attribuerons certaine il n'y a
pas de négociation ce sont des mesures
unilatérales que nous attribuons c'est
l'équivalent ce que les britanniques le
feront leur côté et que nous pouvons
reprendre unilatéralement
c'est très important et on ne coopèrent
pas il n'y a pas de co management de ces
équivalences et puis le domaine dans
lequel ils n'ont pas voulu discuter
c'était déception c'est ce que tu
évoquais qui est celui de la politique
étrangère de sécurité de la défense est
effectué et extérieures et de la
coopération et non pas voulu pourquoi
peut-être parce qu'il voulait tenter de
nous mettre en position de demandeur
peut-être parce qu'il savait qu'il y
avait des intérêts sensibilités
différentes selon les états membres
peut-être aussi parce que cette
dimension-là de la politique européenne
de l'union européenne en tant que
puissance politique en tant qu'acteur
politique n'est pas celle qui privilégie
donc
néanmoins nous sommes ouverts y'a pas de
fébrilité
le jour et bouteilles voudront nous
pourrons discuter et aura une nouvelle
négociation qui seront vers sur ce sujet
là qui était prévu dans la déclaration
politique agréé par bree johnson ya un
an et demi mais dont il n'a pas voulu
discuter et nous sommes prêts à créer un
cadre au terme de nouvelles discussions
par exemple pour la coopération
politique aux nations unies sur la
question des sanctions
la coupe la participation aujourd'hui
les britanniques à des opérations
extérieures militaire de l'union
ils ont participé activement atalante
par exemple est peut-être y aura-t-il
nouvelle volonté de participer avec lui
les opérations extérieures un cadre la
coopération des services la coopération
sur la cybersécurité et puis comme tu
l'as dit la participation en tant que
pays tiers du royaume uni à coopération
structurée que nous qui est mise en
place d'un cadre du traité est également
au fonds d'investissement de la défense
qui vient d'être créée donc voilà ce qui
est et ce qui n'est pas dans le traité
et ce qui est dans le traité ne sera pas
renégocié s'agit de l'appliquer c'est ça
que ray vous dire aux conclusions
il ya trois sujets de vigilance je puis
permettre ou d'exigences un premier
sujet celui de l'irlande liés au premier
traité que j'ai évoqué la paix très
fragile en irlande
2 la bonne application du traité est
mise en place du c'est un tribunal
d'arbitrage partnership continue d'un
conseil de partenariat de l'assemblée
parlementaire le suivi des risques de
dumping et comment on sera informé la
commission par les parlements nationaux
par le par vous parler par les
entreprises par les secteurs concernés y
aura des enquêtes et des outils du
traité seront utilisés mais tout ça est
en train de se mettre en place et ça
explique je le dis en passant sophie des
questions vous avez posée que dans cette
période ce traité ne date que d'un mois
et demi
il ya un besoin d'adaptation de formules
à remplir deux formules douanières mais
il faudra distinguer au bout de quelques
mois ce qui est l'adaptation de
nouvelles règles notamment de contrôle
douanier de skill fonctionnement normal
mesdames et messieurs il faut bien dire
la vérité je voulais toujours dit une
fois vous avez rester ça ne sera pas
business as usual
le brésil ça peut pas être la même chose
qu'avant ils ont quitté le marché unique
ils ont quitté l'union douanière gens
quitter l'union européenne et il s'agit
pas de punition ou de revanche
il s'agit des comptes des conséquences
mécaniques
de ne plus être dans l'union européenne
et dans le marché unique et on peut pas
en allemagne je vais pas le dire aux
français parce que parfois mal compris
mais en allemagne on dit on ne peut pas
aller danser dans deux mariages à la
fois c'est un peu le sujet ils ont
peut-être espérer ça mais c'est pas
possible
et donc il ya une différence durable les
mêmes définitive pour un pays qui est
pays tiers par rapport à un pays qui est
pays membres de l'union et s'agissant du
marché financier ya plus de passeport
financiers s'agissant des certifications
croisé automatique
il ya plus de certification automatique
ya plus de reconnaissance automatique
des qualifications professionnelles
il ya des contrôles de tous les produits
britanniques qui rentrent chez nous
comme eux vont contrôler quand ils le
pourront quand ils le voudront les
produits européens qui rentrent chez eux
et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle chers
collègues des barrières non tarifaires
elles sont nombreuses parce que c'est la
règle avec n'importe quel pays tiers se
termine car le troisième sujet de
vigilance qui me concerne pas tellement
les bréteil puis new concerne ces jeux
qui vous permettre de vous le dire comme
l'homme politique que j'ai toujours été
que je resterai je recommande que l'on
passe un peu de temps pour comprendre
pourquoi le brésil s'est produit c'est
peut-être trop tard de se poser cette
question pour les britanniques c'est pas
trop tard pour nous et pour d'autres
pays européens pourquoi il ya eu ce
rejet de bruxelles de l'union européenne
ou non peut-être de la globalisation et
de ses conséquences dans beaucoup de
régions pauvres ou en difficulté du
royaume uni où l'industrie a disparu
c'est ça c'est ça existe aussi chez nous
la moins de services publics le
sentiment de ne pas être protégée ce
sentiment populaire l'un c'est pas le
populisme cet assentiment populaire que
je recommande d'écouter de comprendre et
auxquelles il faut répondre alors le
brussels commence à y répondre les états
membres aux six mois de naïveté dans nos
échanges
enfin une politique industrielle c'est
plus un gros mot
dans le domaine de la défense et dans
d'autres domaines même si parfois des
difficultés
je recommande de tirer les leçons du
brésil toile à cet autre chose que les
conséquences du président et moi j'ai
été très fier et honoré à ma place dans
tête d'une équipe formidable
d'ailleurs on adjointe clara martinez
doit être en ligne pour y répondre à des
questions syrie il ya des besoins
j'ai été très heureux de participer à ce
travail collectif
je vais rester à bruxelles quelques
semaines de plus pour sur le processus
de ratification parlement européen qui
est en cours et puis je reviendrai
ensuite avec le sentiment d'une mission
accomplie
et dans cette mission il ya un point que
tu a souligné christian qui est celui de
l'unité des 27
on a prouvé que c'était possible ce
n'est pas tombée du ciel
c'est un travail quotidien
d'abord la volonté des 27 chefs d'état
de gouvernement je me souviens très bien
qu'au moment où j'étais désigné c'est
tout en 2016 la situation est
extrêmement grave
monsieur le président vient de se
produire monsieur 30 venez d'être élu il
y avait des attaques terroristes qui
avaient la sécurité tout autour de la
méditerranée
donc le sentiment de gravité de
responsabilité et puis ensuite j'ai
cultivé ce cette volonté d'être unis
pour faire face aux briques site par une
méthode qui a été soutenue par le
président hu au coeur puis par la
présidente von der leyen qui est celui
de la transparence
nous avons tout dit chaque jour à tout
le monde en même temps
voilà comment ça s'est produit il y
avait un groupe de 27 délégués break
site 27 gouvernement qui s'est réuni
deux fois par semaine à bruxelles et
notre équipe a rendu compte de la
négociation en temps réel à ses 27
gouvernements
en même temps et en leur disant la même
chose et donc ils ont une confiance
même chose au parlement européen voilà
et donc ça j'espère simplement je
termine que cette unité sur leur équipe
qui était une négociation négative
comme un divorce est négatif sera
utilisée désormais pour des enjeux
positif ou alors il y en a beaucoup de
vent doux non merci de votre attention
merci michel merci monsieur commissaire
donc nous avons passé si vous louez bien
à la partie des bas je rappelle qu'elle
a fait l'objet d'une organisation un peu
particulière eu égard au fait que nous
sommes réunis à trois commissions et
donc chaque groupe a été sollicité pour
désigner ces orateurs qui s'en tiendront
à une minutes par question je vous
demande vérité contenue de la liste
impressionnante des orateurs je pense
que dans l'intérêt de tout le monde les
de notre invité il sera utile de
respecter cette règle est donc sans plus
tarder je donne la parole à pascal
allizard pour une minute au type de la
commission affaires étrangères et des
affaires européennes
oui je le président merci monsieur milan
10 persie pour cet exposé et je joins
mes félicitations à celles qui vous ont
été adressées pour cette mission hors
norme
il y à l'accord et puis il ya la
relation future
on est bien évidemment tous vigilants
sur les problématiques de défense de
pêche au port de commerce et un élu
lormand qui vous le dit il y aussi
l'accord bilatéral entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne mais il
y a aussi les intérêts de la france au
sein de cet accord est ce que vous
pourriez nous donner quelques précisions
le président a peint la vie concernant
les ports on voit bien la stratégie de
nos amis hollandais et belges
donc voilà un éclairage sur ce point
m'intéresserait et un point aussi très
particulier parce que c'est un peu mon
dada dans cette maison si je puis dire
y at il une stratégie chinoise connue
pour tirer les marrons du feu de ce
divorce j'ai tenu mon temps monsieur le
président en fait je donnerai des bons
points à l'issue de la réunion
immédiatement par visio jean marc
todeschini
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le commissaire monsieur le
ministre barnier
on est content j'avais à l'esprit le
dessin de plantu qui illustre
parfaitement
la reconnaissance que vous avez il nous
est peut-être le seul à avoir de tous
les enjeux de cette négociation qui a
été menée je voudrais aussi vous dire
que j'ai apprécié votre marque finale en
disant qu'il fallait que les autres pays
se pose la question de savoir pourquoi
le raid si tu avais et étaient
intervenus et c'est très important si
nous ne voulons pas que les populistes
de toutes sortes progresse dans les 27
autres pays
enfin il devra aborder même si vous avez
grosse et évoqué un peu l'enseignement
la recherche
j'aurais évoqué d'enseignement supérieur
qui va au delà du programme erasmus
quid des programmes de coopération en
matière de recherche entre les
laboratoires situés des deux côtés de la
frontière
la frontière quid de la mobilité des
enseignants des chercheurs et du
personnel administratif car nous le
savons la mobilité et à ta d'amy qui est
un élément essentiel de collaboration en
développement
d'après les évaluations de la conférence
des présidents d'université plus de
45000 articles scientifiques son côté
écrit entre la france et le royaume uni
dans les sciences dures dans les sons
fumel dans les sciences sociales et
autres
quid des contrats d'enseignement dehors
de recherche et d'innovation entre les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
temps des contrats déjà signés
les développements futurs quelle est la
matérialisation concrète dans le cadre
du président de la convention signée
entre la conférence des présidents
d'université et leurs homologues
britanniques en juin 2017 qui a
réaffirmé cette volonté commune de
travailler ensemble prime j'avais je
crois que nous ressentons notamment à
travers la crise du pot vide la
nécessité d'une internationalisation
d'un renforcement des liens entre les
études de recherche et par le monde
enfin pour terminer j'aurais revenir sur
la la question couverture des nouvelles
voies maritimes avaient d'irlande nos
partenaires européens en tort et déjà
travailler afin d'ouvrir de nouvelles
routes vers la république d'irlande
à ce stade c'est démarche relève
essentiellement de volonté bilatérales
l'union ne sera la mieux à même de
coordonner et d'organiser ces nouvelles
routes non seulement
d'investissements en infrastructures
elle l'est plus encore afin de mettre en
oeuvre une véritable politique
européenne des transports
fondamentalement inscrits dans un cadre
de préservation et de valorisation
environnement pas je vous remercie
ça c'est le tempérament généreux des
élus de l'est c'est une grosse minute
donc après l'orateur heller jean-marc au
titre du groupe socialiste au titre des
ou centriste olivier cadic merci
monsieur le président sur le commissaire
vous avez dit que quatre millions et
demi d'euros p11 eu leurs droits acquis
grâce donc à l'accord de sortie bien je
fais partie de ceux là
donc je voudrais vous remercier vous
remercier pour vos efforts et
l'attention que vous nous avez porté
tout au long de ces négociations
en leur nom et en le mien je veux vous
remercier pour cela je souhaite évoquer
un besoin de clarification de l'article
20 de l'accord de sortie restriction des
droits de séjour et d'entrée il m'a été
soumis par nicolas ton président 2,6
milliards cela concerne 2 millions
d'européens qui ont actuellement le
puits settle status savait que au bout
de cinq ans dans le set à l'us donc deux
millions d'entre eux n'ont que le plus
est le status les britanniques prévoient
que pour eux il faudra qu'ils
renouvellent leur demande de cet oeil
status dans les cinq ans l'article 20 de
l'accord de sortie stipule les raisons
justifiant une perte de statut et le il
y a donc ils s'ajustent hi-fi la perte
de statut et de résidence l'omission de
refaire la demande n'en fait pas partie
que sera que se passera-t-il dans ce cas
certains pensent qu'ils perdraient leurs
droits d'autres pas une clarification
est attendue je remercie
merci olivier au titre du groupe air des
pays riches à riom merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le commissaire
ma question porte sur un des points que
vous avez évoquées qui n'est pas dans
l'accord les services financiers
à l'heure actuelle a depuis le 1er
janvier les acteurs financiers
britanniques ont perdu leur passeport
européen donc qu'ils ne peuvent plus
exercer leur activité sur nos
territoires et on voit bien d'ailleurs
qu'il ya eu déjà un transfert des
activités financières de londres vers
amsterdam francfort et paris
dans cet ordre donc il faut que la
commission donne un accord une
équivalence ce qu'on appelle une
équivalence est pour l'instant vous
l'avez fait avec parcimonie puisqu'il y
en a je crois 2 alors qu'il y en a une
trentaine en attente
il y a dans l'accord une déclaration qui
prévoit l'établissement d'ici mars 2021
c'est à dire le mois prochain d'un
protocole d'accord définissant le cadre
d'une coopération réglementaire en
matière de services financiers
donc ma question et qu'en est il de
cette négociation parce que vous avancez
avec les britanniques sur ce la mise en
oeuvre de ce protocole est ce que vous
avez un espoir que ça puisse aboutir
et comment voyez vous les choses merci
merci richard au titre du groupe crc eux
mais je ne vois pas pierre laurent
est-ce que père laurent est en séance ou
quelques faux plats peut-être est-il en
vision oui le mien j'avais pas je
n'avais pas mon écran de retour au pays
pierre laurent oui merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le commissaire
pour votre exposé ma question très
rapide elle portait sur ce que vous avez
abordé dans le troisième point de
vigilance les leçons politiques du break
site
j'avais un peu l'impression que après
être passé par un climat très très dur
très anxiogène au moment du bric site
lui même
on était passé à un climat de ouf de
soulagement après l'accord que vous avez
vous avez négocié et avec un risque
c'est d'oublier l'échec politique de
constituer et que constitue le break
site pour l'europe non je suis heureux
de vous avoir entendu dire le contraire
et 2 ne vous entendra appelé à
poursuivre la réflexion parce que il ya
effectivement je suis parent je fais
partie de ceux là avec nous des gens qui
ne veulent pas à sortir de l'union
européenne mais qui porte un certain
nombre de débats et de critiques qui ont
le sentiment depuis maintenant des
années de ne pas être écoutés et ceux
qui à mon avis continue
nourrir des phénomènes qui peuvent
conduire au rejet de l'europe et des
phénomènes regrettable donc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
un show comme ça vous quelle grande
leçon politique justement vous vous
tirées de cet échec politique qui a
constitué le break side pour l'union
européenne où va entamer un débat pour
repenser l'avenir de l'europe
est-ce que vous avez quelques pistes à
soumettre pour ce qui devrait changer
pour l'avenir de l'europe merci
voilà merci donc pour la bonne
compréhension des pages propose à michel
barnier de répondre à cette première
question ça sera forcément
peut-être que j'étais trop long et je
vous prie de l'en excuser mais peu
télégraphique météo moi j'ai pris bonne
note de toutes les questions peut-être
sur l'un d'entre elles clar martinez je
pensais à la question que pose et
olivier cadic sur l'article 20 pourrait
dire un mot si vous lui autoriser pascal
allizard a évoqué les intérêts français
naturellement dans la position je me
trouve encore ici comme négociateur et
est aujourd'hui poursuivre je ne vais
pas
renverser les rôles vous n'aurez pas
beaucoup à attendre si je puis dire dès
maintenant je serai dégager de mes
responsabilités européennes pour que je
reprenne ma part simplement mais avec
détermination dans le débat politique
français et je veux exprimer sur ce
qu'il faut par exemple en termes de
stratégie industrielle
ça ne doit plus être un gros mot comme
cela a été trop longtemps à bruxelles ou
pour répondre à pierre laurent à
l'instant les leçons du bric site
oui enfin je j'ai des idées assez
précise sur les raisons pour lesquelles
je le disais tout à l'heure dans
beaucoup de régions et c'est pour ça que
je recommande de faire attention parce
que ce sentiment populaire il existe
chez nous chez nous beaucoup plus qu'on
le croit il dit qu'on pense que l'europe
n'a pas protégée des excès de la
mondialisation
je vais aller un peu plus loin puis à
laurent battut vous faire plaisir
je sais pas pour faire plaisir dès que
je dis ça c'est parce que je le pense
il y a eu à bruxelles et pendant trop
d'années
soutenu par des gouvernements de droite
et de gauche une forme d'ultra
libéralisme qui a consisté à déréguler à
ouvrir toutes les portes et toutes les
fenêtres alors que ni les chinois les
américains et les russes
ouvrez toutes leurs portes toutes les
fenêtres et que on a baissé la garde
on a baissé la garde s'agissant
notamment de la régulation financière
et quand la crise est arrivée en 2008
elle a heurté de plein fouet un
continent européen qui n'était pas armé
ou plutôt qu'il était désarmé
à force de déréguler je le dis d'autant
plus clairement que je suis devenu
commissaire européen n'avait pas nicolas
sarkozy quelques temps plus tard en 2010
et que j'ai eu comme une commissaire aux
services financiers à reconstruire cette
régulation
j'ai présenté avec mon équipe quarante
et une loi 40 une loi de régulation
financière en cinq ans chaque secteur
chaque service chaque produit pour
remettre la transparence de la lumière
sur des gens qui n'aiment pas beaucoup
la lumière un croyez-moi peu morale et
d'éthique là où elles avaient disparu
c'est ça que j'ai eu
l'heure de faire pendant cinq ans dans
mon deuxième mandat de commissaire et ça
a été des raisons de la faiblesse de
l'europe en royaume uni en irlande en
france
le choc de la crise qui tourne aurait
tort d'oublier
je pourrais aussi parler des excès de la
bureaucratie de de cette tendance qu'ont
qu'on a eu au niveau national c'est pas
tellement au niveau européen mais d
industrialiser au profit des services
aux réunir fait ça la france a fait ça
mais papa l'allemagne pas l'italie papa
là bas la suède
donc je pense qu'ils maintenant dans le
monde tel qu'il est qui est un monde
global on a intérêt à son plan de plein
d'industrie mais l'industrie numérique
qui rit breton est en charge de 500 de
cube activement mais aussi l'industrie
de la défense de réarmer l'europe et
d'avoir une stratégie européenne va
fâcher très heureux par exemple que le
fonds d'investissement de défense
christian et pour la première fois il ya
de l'argent européen dans le budget de
l'union européenne qui va être affectés
à des investissements de la défense
soixante ans après la création de
l'union voilà quelques exemples et puis
je pourrais ajouter les pleurants la
faiblesse du débat démocratique européen
j'ai eu beaucoup de démagogie mais pas
seulement la démagogie dans la question
du référendum général de gaulle qui
disait un jour dans un discours il faut
combattre la démagogie par la démocratie
phrase que j'aime bien et je pense que
c'est en partie la solution c'est pas la
raison du mexique n'est pas seulement
celle là me met
comprenez moi bien je pense que on doit
aussi être capable d'avoir un débat
démocratique parce que je pense que les
peuples sont intelligents et qu' ils
doivent avoir les éléments pour décider
voilà donc je je voudrais relier la
question de pascal allizard à celle de
jean marc todeschini qui parlait
notamment des nouvelles routes de
transport
j'ai entendu l'autre jour un reportage
sur ce qui se passe à cherbourg par
exemple ou de nouvelles lignes de fret
direct entre cherbourg et l'irlande font
que le trafic a augmenté
considérablement à cherbourg je veux
qu'on trouve peut-être les élus qui sont
sur place donc il ya il ya une heure et
un chemin pour créer avec l'irlande qui
2 qui est demandeur et pas seulement en
matière de transport mais aussi en
matière d'énergie moins de dépendance et
plus de lien direct et la commission est
prête à encourager et soutenir ces liens
donc la stratégie chinoise pascal donc
c'est qu'il existe il faut pas être naïf
je pense qu'elle existe très précis tout
pabr excitant voilà je pense néanmoins
que c'est peut-être une des raisons
supplémentaires comme d'ailleurs la
stratégie américaine celle de train pour
celle de john ryle pas attendre faut pas
être naïf non plus des raisons pour
lesquelles ne devra absolument
quoi qu'on pense de l'europe et ses
défaillances ou de cete faut préserver
le marché unique et ça a été pour moi la
ligne bleue permanent de cette
négociation pas pas d'affaiblissement
palette cherry picking
on peut pas se permettre ça la simple
raison que la principale raison pour
laquelle les américains et les chinois
nous respecte
c'est le marché unique et c'est le
principal atout est donc vie la vie des
chinois comme d autres préservant ce
marché et bâtissons des politiques ou
des répliques mais nous savons que les
stratégies existent
jean marc todeschini évoqué dessin de
plantu
tout le monde n'a pas compris mais
l'honneur d'avoir pour la première fois
dans ma vie publique un dessin de plantu
runes qui disait en gros on montre la
complexité du bric site dans ma bouche
si vous avez compris ce que je disais
c'est que je me suis mal exprimé
donc j'espère que c'est pas tout à fait
le sentiment que vous avez aujourd'hui
mais bon il faut parfois ça fait du bien
de recevoir des donc l'université et
l'élaborateur continuera à coopérer
parce que le royaume uni ait accepté de
participer au prime de recherche
ça sera pas le même cadre financier ce
ne sera pas le même cadre juridique mais
ils ont accepté de participer mais je
pense que cette intelligente de
continuer la coopération dans ce domaine
olivier cadic a évoqué l'article 20 je
ne suis pas informé de ce problème
peut-être car allait-elle si elle veut
prendre la parole en tout cas tous ces
problèmes font l'objet quand ils nous
sont soumis de débats de son mise à
l'agenda de ce qu'on appelle le john
committee le comité conjoint entre le
royaume uni et nous pour vérifier
l'application correcte de l'accord de
retrait dont tu parle donc presque car
tu ne réponds sur cet article 20 cl
clara martinez et la non que est-ce que
vous m'entendez oui oui tout bruit
bonsoir michèle manceaux à tout le monde
oui c'est une problématique en effet on
a discuté déjà plusieurs fois au sein du
comité spécialisé avec les britanniques
et au sein du comité conjoint
il en resterait un système selon lequel
certains catégorie de citoyens avaient
droit au statut de résident permanent
s'ils remplissent les conditions
c'est-à-dire avoir être au royaume uni
avant le 31 décembre de l'année dernière
et pour certains autres catégories
avaient étendu sa en donnant un tas une
catégorie de prêts résidents permanents
ce qui signifie qu'un certain moment
effectivement le renouveler mais compte
aux droits qui sont prévues par l'accord
de retrait le britannique ne peuvent pas
les mettre en discussion c'est une
procédure administrative qui l'ont mis
en place que la commission surveille
pouvoirs qui ait pas de difficultés
chaque état membre aussi à instaurer
certains des systèmes purement
déclaratoire d'autres des systèmes
constitutive où il faut suivre une
procédure pour les résidents
britanniques qui sont dans les pays dans
les états membres avant le 31 décembre
mais le droit en tant que tel le
britannique ne peuvent pas le refuser
il ya une procédure administrative qui
s'applique à certaines catégories mais
qui ne peut pas mettre en question les
droits qui sont prévus dans l'accord de
retrait et la commission suit ça de près
continuera à le suivre dans l'est dans
les prochains mois dans le projet que
j'aime dire que l'art martinez de vous
rappeler cette question à monsieur
sefcovic le vice président de la
commission européenne qui nous
représente
nous européens dans ce comité conjoint à
martinez qui est exprimée est hélas des
drisses de cabinet du président juncker
et elle est aujourd'hui pour 15 jours
encore mon adjointe dans la négociation
elle était à mes côtés dans toute cette
deuxième négociation
richard yong a évoqué les procédures
d'équivalence nous faisons procédure
d'évaluation des équivalences il ya une
bonne vingtaine qui sont envisagés ou
possible elles ne seront pas tout donné
elles sont été attribuées de manière
très consciencieuse en tenant compte de
nos intérêts et des risques de stabilité
financière les britanniques ont essayé
dans la négociation de contourner cette
procédure
par exemple ils ont jusqu'au dernier
moment insisté pour mettre dans l'accord
de route de futures relations
une disposition qui ouvrait une sorte
d'équivalence automatique pour tout ce
qu'on appelle le portfolio management
des fonds d'investissement trois mille
milliards de roi et président de la
commission est extrêmement clair et net
pas question on ne contourne pas il n'y
a pas de co management de les procédures
d'équivalence est trop important pour
pour ce secteur là c'est un vrai
changement
peut-être tout le monde n'a pas cru
qu'il allait se produire mais ces
produits comme une conséquence mécanique
automatique du prg excités et nous
travaillons
la commissaire marine mcguinness qui est
irlandaise et qui se chargeait des
services financiers travaillent
actuellement au protocole que tu as
évoqué et qui sera fait dans les délais
prévus
mais c'est pas un protocole qui concerne
les équivalences on anticipe à on ne
traite pas d'équivalence est un
protocole sur la coopération
réglementaire en matière financière
comme nous en avons 1 avec le japon et
un autre avec les états unis
voilà bon pierre laurent et vous que non
il n'y a pas de soulagement
prochainement je paye pouvait de
soulagement j'étais content de cette
mission et surtout d'aboutir à un accord
pour un divorce ordonné plutôt que
désordonné mais je pense que le
président reste une interpellation et je
vais pas revenir sur les réponses que
j'ai fait tout allait bien nous
attaquons la deuxième série de cinq
questions commencent par un jean noël
guérini pour le rds en visio jean noël
président maurel ministre bravo d'un
point de vue de notre continent le
benfica était présenté comme un
cataclysme pour le royaume uni
au premier rang les anglais avait plus à
perdre que les européens en tétant
l'union à montoir et projections longue
sur l'évolution du pib d'ici 2050
l'union européenne se maintiendrait au
sein du g8 tandis que le royaume uni en
sortir et pourtant lorsque l'on observe
que les britanniques ont été mieux
fournis en bac 5 comme contre le comique
cela interroge sommes-nous la phase un
épisode n et d'optique ou une
illustre-t-il les angles morts qui
persiste au sein de
la grande-bretagne et j'allais dire de
l'accord de commerce et de coopération
dont pourrait finalement profiter la
grande bretagne
je pense en particulier au volet sur les
garanties relatives à la concurrence
loyale
l'union européenne a par exemple
renoncer à la ville du mans dynamique
des normes ou encore quelles garanties
opérons offriront les britanniques sur
la question de l'accès aux marchés
publics très encadrés par des directives
attend vraiment promener de bon
équilibre entre compétition et
coopération merci france mais nos villes
pour les indépendants merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure donc les leçons à
tirer du brésil
à ce stade moi je vous voudrez peut être
vous demander dans quelle de caumont
peut-être qu'elles sont la nature pour
faire rebondir donc la construction
européenne avec quels leviers et surtout
quelle évolution institutionnelle
pouvez-vous peut-être
nous nous évoquer ces évolutions
possibles et surtout donc comment ré
enchanter donc la construction
européenne et notamment convaincre nos
nos concitoyens européens que l'europe
ait véritablement à liogier permettant
de garantir demain la souveraineté de
notre économique de nos deux nations est
une autre question peut-être concernant
peut-être le la situation de la hongrie
et à moindre mesure la pologne sur les
grandes libertés qu'elle qui sont prises
actuellement sur les valeurs fondatrices
de l'europe et de nos démocraties
libérales
comment voyez vous donc ce risque et
puis enfin vous évoquez tout à l'heure
les halls et des enjeux de dérégulation
il ya un dossier effectivement qui qui
fait débat qui a fait débat qui nous
inquiète c'est celui de la situation de
notre entreprise publique edf et comment
voyez vous donc son avenir possible
jacques fernique pour le groupe
écologiste oui merci de vos explications
très claires et votre engagement
cette négociation vous l'avez dit elle a
été marquée je suis là par là la volonté
des vingt-sept d'assurer comment dire la
robustesse de ce nouvel accord de
commerce pour contrer les risques de
dumping autant environnementaux sociaux
l'essentiel sera donc dans la pratique
dans l' usage de ce traité selon notre
formule pour que les effets de suivi
correspondent aux effets d annonce il y
aura donc tout un mécanisme de
vérification du respect nos standards
environnementaux et sociaux qui est
amené à se déployer deux questions très
précises la première vous quelles
garanties sur la robustesse de ce
mécanisme sur les sanctions les
restrictions en cas d'écart et deuxième
question j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment sur la possibilité
l'opportunité d'élargir en quelque sorte
le champ d'application de cette nouvelle
logique de cette nouvelle disposition
européenne
est ce que ça pourrait être appliqué à
d'autres accords commerciaux autrement
dit y at il possibilité pour que de ce
mal en quelque sorte certains bien de
faire bouger le modèle actuel de
l'accord commercial européen encore trop
marqué par la seule volonté d'ouverture
et de circulation la plus aisé possible
encore trop marqué par
l'ultra-libéralisme joëlle
garriaud-maylam pour le groupe l'est
républicain
oui merci beaucoup le principal problème
du protocole irlandais et la création
d'une frontière en mer d'irlande
les tensions qu'elles créent les
unionistes dudit youpi invoque de plus
en plus l'article 16 du protocole nord
irlandais qui autorise le royaume uni à
prendre des mesures de sauvegarde
appropriées donc une possible suspension
des contrôles
le 11 février dernier michael gove et
mareuil chef shawn mitch pardon ont
publié un communiqué conjoint sur les
prochaines étapes et d'éventuels
ajustements
c'est ton monsieur le ministre quelles
pourraient être ces aménagements et ne
risque-t-on pas de remettre en cause les
fondamentaux de ce protocole qui fait
polémique au royaume uni car il met
l'irlande du nord dans une situation de
double appartenance et enfin peut-être
sur les droits des citoyens ce qui ne
serait pas utile d'envisager un comité
vraiment spécifique qu'ils puissent
contrôler la réciprocité des droits
entre citoyens européens et citoyens
britanniques
merci si joël franck montaugé pour le
groupe socialiste
merci merci monsieur bernier je suppose
que les négociations se sont appuyés sur
une analyse des risques économiques
encourus par les pays de l'union
européenne à côte deux tenues de
l'accord négocié dans quels secteurs où
filière économique anticipée vous des
conséquences négatives
quel plan ou contre mesures l'état
français devrait il mettre en oeuvre
pour minimiser ses effets sur les
entreprises françaises par exemple les
services financiers implantées en france
ne vont-ils pas en pâtir
ne voyez vous pas dans le départ des
britanniques
une opportunité de création de nouveaux
paradis fiscaux sachant que cette
question des paradis fiscaux n'est pas
toujours pas résolu en europe et même en
matière agricole
l'accord laisse comprendre que nous ne
pourrons plus protéger les futurs iger p
ou aop
comme nous l'avons fait jusqu'ici les
accords futurs résultats de l'évaluation
du break site initial feront ils partie
de l'accord de break cite le cas des
indications géographiques protégées est
un exemple parmi d'autres et enfin le
vrai le break site va-t-il selon vous
alourdir ou faciliter le projet
nucléaire dit que les poètes que porte
edf je vous remercie j'en ai peut-être
si je peux demander qu'on montre le
tableau chapelle tableau cameron non
c'est les deux tableaux de pour vous
montrer ce qu'il en est dur de risque
digeo ou fait d'être seul ou d'être
ensemble
peut-être on peut trouver ce tableau non
[Musique]
fait pas celui là
voilà ça tableau que que j'aime bien
montrer parce que l'état c'est un
cameron effet ce tableau sur la partie
gauche pour montrer l'importance d'être
ensemble dans le marché unique et ce
tableau montre pour le connaissez
peut-être tous les dix ans que
deviennent les pays du g8 économique est
seul on est progressivement les quatre
pays européens qui en font partie
allemagne royaume uni italie et france
éjecté l'un des quatre est éjecté en
2050 il ya plus que l'allemagne
alors j'ai refait le tableau et mêmes
chiffres actualisés prospectives tout
cette prospective et on voit que
ensemble les 27 restent à la table est
seul on est progressivement éjecté c'est
la question fondamentale d'être europe
est patriote comme je dis quelquefois
mais de deux d'être en plus européenne
que d'être chacun chez soi parce que ça
donne une force qui nous permet d'être à
la table les conséquences jean noël
guérini du prg excite on les avait
évalué à près 3% de pib sur plusieurs
années pour le royaume-uni 0.34 pour
l'union européenne mais b genre je
rejoins sympa pour la dernière question
que franck montaugé a pas apporté le
président cellou blues c'est perdant
perdant
il n'y a pas de bien pas de conséquences
positives du bric site et je crois même
pas pu vous parler des services
financiers français ou autres ils sont
plutôt renforcé puisque il ya des
transferts qu'on vous l'a vu avec le
trading d'actions qui ce transfert ça
c'est les conséquences du fait que les
britanniques perdent le passeport
financer mais je suis pas sûr qu'il
faille s'en réjouir mais je ne vois pas
ou que je regarde de conséquences
positives au brésil
donc évidemment plus de conséquences
négatives au royaume-uni puisque le
structure des échanges est clairement
pour eux un problème
puis ce qu'ils exportent 47% vers
l'union européenne de leur marchandise
donc toutes ses marchandises il n'y a
pas de taxe et il n'y a pas de quotas
mais il ya des contrôles et donc des
barrières non tarifaires donc sur les
vaccins j'en ai je vais je ne vais pas
faire de commentaire
sauf pour dire qu'il faut mettre les
choses en perspective tant mieux s'il ya
plus de britanniques qui sont vaccinées
on voit bien qu'on peut discuter aussi
du vaccin quand ils sentent vraiment
opérationnel il faut deux de deux
injections et beaucoup de premières
injections beaucoup moins de 2 de deux
injections
c'est clair que les britanniques sont
seuls qu'ils ont pu décider seul et que
c'est plus compliqué décidé à 27 surtout
quand c'est la première fois et nous la
ville l'office était qu' on commandait
ont mutualisé les commandes de vaccins
avec peut-être difficultés
administratives plus lourde parce qu'on
est 27 mai qu'au moins on garantissait
une équité entre les 27
c'est aussi ça la philosophie l'union
européenne attend je recommande de
mettre les choses en perspective on va
voir dans quelques mois comment les
choses se passent et je veux dire qu'il
faut éviter des polémiques sur ce sujet
qu'il faut éviter de la surenchère
tant mieux pour les britanniques moi je
leur souhaite tout le meilleur
ce que je veux dire c'est que il y aura
tellement de sujets entre nous par
rapport au monde tel qu'il vient sur les
nouvelles pandémies il faut pas se faire
d'illusions il y en aura d'autres
animales ou humaines des risques de
terrorisme
le changement climatique les questions
d'instabilité financière
il y aura tellement de sujets graves qui
vont être devant nous pour ceux qui vont
gouverner nos pays qu' il faut préserver
l'esprit de coopération était
britannique voit ce que je pense donc au
pré cités derrière nous je je je
recommande de ne pas faire de cr7 est
pas là la question mais je recommande
que pour mettre cette question là des
vaccins aux perspectives
voilà
frank moore il a évoqué le sujet qui
sont en dehors du bric site jeu j'aurais
plus la liberté de m'exprimer sur ces
sujets mais ce qu'il faut faire en
europe mais je les ai déjà dit un peu
tout à l'heure en répondant à pierre
laurent
je suis pas sûr pour tout vous dire que
il faut mettre les questions
institutionnelles en premier rang de
l'agenda
on a fait ça et c'est de mon point de
vue ça a été une erreur qu'en disant gg
contribuent d'ailleurs aux négociations
du traité d'amsterdam comme ministre
comme commissaire traité de nice la
constitution européenne
on sait on a mis toute notre énergie sur
ses formes institutionnelles je suis pas
sûr que ça intéresse beaucoup les gens
pensent que ce qui est intéressant ce
n'est pas le moteur c'est qui doit
fonctionner on vous doit réformer ce
qu'il faut c'est plutôt qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ensemble
pourquoi on est sur la même route
quelles sont les prochaines étapes sur
cette route c'est ça qui me paraît
important et est peut-être jédir jeunes
un peu plus loin qu'on comprenne le
temps au niveau européen du peut-être au
niveau national aussi d'évaluer quelle
est la valeur ajoutée de ce qu'on fait
ensemble
il ya peut-être des sujets qu'on a mis
ensemble il ya 20 ans ou 30 ans 40 ans
qui n'ont plus la même valeur ajoutée
pierre nouveaux sujets là je rencontrais
le président du cnrs pour la recherche
la santé la défense qui sont des sujets
qu'il faut absolument mettre ensemble à
façonner t on a besoin de mutualiser
c'est un mot que j'aime bien pour écrire
l'europe que c'est ça la question
voilà donc jeu de questions la valeur
ajoutée pour moi elle est très
importante
ou est ce qu'on a dans quel domaine une
valeur ajoutée agir ensemble
ou est ce qu'on en a plus ou pas je prie
je prétends pas qu'il faut tout mettre
ensemble langres et la pologne sont en
discussions avec l'union européenne les
étoiles quand on est membre de l'union
respecter règles notamment sur les
droits fondamentaux pour aider m je veux
pas me prononcer parce sujette à
l'instruction comme on dit par les
services de la commission jacques
fernique a évoqué la robustesse des
clauses je serais tenter de vous dire je
les experts avec lesquels j'ai travaillé
me disent que ce qu'on a fait et
crédible à la fois pour les aides
détails pour la non régression khiter et
environnementaux sociaux fiscaux
maintenant je serai aussi pour être tout
à fait sincère dire qu'ils vont avoir un
usage
j'espère qu'on en aura pas usage pour
tout vous dire j'espère que les mesures
qu'on a prévu auront un effet dissuasif
ou préventif mais il faut être vigilant
j'ai déjà entendu trois ministres je
crois depuis trois semaines un mois
britannique qui a annoncé des mesures
sur d'assouplissement de la durée
hebdomadaire du travail
l'introduction de pesticides et
assouplissement des règles prudentielles
dans les services financiers
donc on a des raisons de vigilance mais
on verra à l'usagé que ma réponse est
oui à votre deuxième question la
présence de la commission a dit je vous
confirme que ce que nous avons fait la
servira de base pour tous les nouveaux
accords de commerce dans le monde que
nous signerons tant qu'européen donc il
s'agira plus seulement d'abaisser ou de
supprimer les tarifs à s'abaisser de
supprimer les quotas et de buzet
d'utiliser nos outils de f kg et
d'accords de libre-échange comme un
outil de gouvernance mondiale pour clé
du progrès notamment dans le domaine de
la lutte contre le changement climatique
bien sûr ces accords ne ressembleront
pas tous à celui ci est ce que nous
avons fait c'est la première fois pour
les règles du jeu équitables sera
réutilisé joël je vais pas revenir sur
le débat que j'ai longtemps que 10 du
pis le parti unioniste les difficultés
je veux pas parler de frontières plus de
contrôle
donc je je ne dirais pas qu'il ya une
frontière dans la mer il ya une taie des
contrôles dans un espace qui est régi
par les règles du marché unique où le
code douanier européen s'applique et
nous devons faire ce contrôle pour les
trois raisons que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure je ne veux pas les frontières
parce que je veux qu'on respecte
l'intégrité territoriale
une politique du royaume uni ce
protocole n'est pas négociable
il a fait l'objet d'un traité ratifié et
doit être respectée dans toutes ses
dimensions ne vous souvenez la tentative
un peu étonnante que les britanniques
ont fait il ya à peu près six mois quand
ils ont voulu remettre en cause
plusieurs dispositions de ce protocole
sa sollicité notre stupeur la stupeur de
plusieurs anciens premier britannique
dont madame même la qualité de la
signature britannique est aussi la
réaction du nouveau président américain
qui est très attentif à ce qui se passe
en irlande je baille de l'ain et du coup
ils sont revenus en arrière plus de
raison donc je recommande d'être
pragmatique nous sommes pragmatiques
dans le comité conjoint
il ya déjà d'ailleurs je le dis et joël
un comité spécialisé sur les droits des
citoyens dans le comité conjoint mais un
comité conjoint globale et puis il ya
plusieurs comités spécialisés dont un
sur les citoyens
mais je nous continuerons d'être
pragmatique et de tirer les leçons de
l'erreur qui a été faite il ya quinze
jours voilà et franc que vous avez
évoqué les conséquences négatives jeu
j'ai dit ce que je pensais
[Musique]
il se trouve que j'ai l'honneur d'être
mise d'agriculture et donc je suis très
attaché aux indications géographiques
le stock des 3000 indication
géographique a été sécurisé
définitivement dans l'accord de retrait
le même que celui de l'irlande des
citoyens le même 3000
les britanniques ont voulu réouvrir cet
accord nous avons refusé lorsqu'il
réserve ne vont pas dans le nouvel
accord prêté la question des nouvelles
indications géographiques
il n'aura très peu et nous sommes
convenus de rendez vous pour discuter de
ça avec eux mais moi ce qui me passait
plus important dans une négoce et cunego
un set c'était de préserver le stock
puis 3000 y compris les indications
géographiques le whisky écossais par
exemple je suis bien que hors gorgonzola
pour le beaufort
je dis comme ça parce que j'étais député
du beaufort pendant très longtemps donc
on la faisait très bien monsieur le
commissaire dernière salve de questions
anne catherine loisier pour l'union
centriste
merci madame la présidente monsieur mais
messieurs les présidents monsieur le
ministre
moi je voudrais revenir ce mini sûr
s'agissant des notamment donc des
questions environnementales sur sur
cette clause de non régression des
niveaux de production qui se veut être
contraignante est exécutoire et qui
pouvaient de ce que vous nous en dit
semble semble solide suffisant pour
éviter les écueils d'une concurrence
déloyale ou d'un dumping environnemental
mais qu'en est il en fait des moyens
opérationnels pour pour assurer la mise
en oeuvre de cette clause tout à l'heure
le président rap a évoqué l'organisation
d'un groupe de travail mixte union
européenne et royaume uni donc pour
superviser les contrôles aux principaux
points d'entrée de l'union européenne
donc qu'en est il au delà donc de la
formule pas de business as usual quelles
seront donc les moyens pour pour
l'assurer et la mettre en oeuvre
et puis pour rebondir sur la question
finale qui est la vôtre et qui
effectivement est essentielle pourquoi
le bric site at il eu lieu c'est
effectivement essentiel que nous
parlements nationaux nous en emparer
lyon mais l'administration européenne
s'interroge t elle aussi
merci à une catherine pierre kuipers
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
commissaire d'avoir remercie de votre
pugnacité pour avoir abouti à cet accord
c'était quelque chose que nous avons
suivie de près et qui vous honore et qui
honore notre pays
mais l'accord n'est pas forcément bon
pour tout le monde on le sait je pendrai
à titre d'exemple pour bien comprendre
la filière sucre nous exportons la
france exporte 500 mille tonnes de sucre
vers le quotidien britannique
certes ce volume ne sera pas interrompue
par des barrières tarifaires et c'est
une bonne chose mais ce sera plus
pernicieux nous seront exclus de ce
marché pour des raisons économiques
sachant que les britanniques se sont
accordés un nouveau comptage ans sans
droit de douane de sucre de kde donc non
communautaires de l'ordre de 260 mille
têtes c'était plus de la moitié de ce
que nous exportons sur la grande
bretagne
nous y serons donc directement en
concurrence avec le sucre brésilien nous
risquons donc d'être petit à petit exclu
pour des critères économiques car il
nous faudra rivaliser avec les plus
compétitifs des pays tiers
de plus les contingents d'importation
que la commission à négocier en
bilatéral je dis bien en bilatéral et
pas en quentin jean de l'om c'est reste
en l'état
on pourra donc importer sur l'union
européenne à 27 ce qui avait été négocié
à 28 ce qui va nous pénaliser davantage
puisque des volumes de commercialisation
qui ne seront pas prêts par la grande
bretagne seront à la charge de notre
pays alors voilà pensez vous monsieur le
commissaire pouvoir pousser la dg trade
à rouvrir ses négociations bilatérales
la fenêtre de tir serait opportune
d'autant plus avec le green deal où des
voix s'élèvent pour demander d'exiger de
nos partenaires commerciaux
traditionnels ce que l'on va exiger à
nos propres producteurs
merci merci pierre jean yves le conte
oui merci madame la présente mais si
monsieur le commissaire de deux
questions monsieur le
comme ici à la première l'accord de
retrait d'abord est fait référence à au
droit de l'union et au respect du droit
de l'union sur un certain nombre de
sujets en particulier en ce qui concerne
les citoyens européens ont pourtant à
partir d'une certaine période ce sera
plus la cge qui pourra décider mais ce
sera un tribunal d'arbitrage
est ce que ça ne remet pas en cause la
primauté et l'exclusivité de la cgu en
matière de droit de l'union
deuxième question et vous avez évoqué le
fait que ce nouvel accord pourrait
servir de base pour d'autres accords
c'est un accord complexe et pourtant il
ne sera pas ratifiée par les parlements
nationaux
on peut comprendre pourquoi contenu du
point de départ toutefois comme mort
derrière imaginer que des accords qui
seraient moins intégrés et moins
complexes ou de même nature ne passe pas
devant les parlements nationaux si
celui-là n'est pas passé devant les
parlements nationaux en d'autres titres
est-ce que de cette manière on ne crée
pas un précédent qui pourrait par
exemple justifier que tous les autres
accords du type c'est à autre ne passe
plus devant les parlements nationaux si
on appliquer les mêmes règles
thibault coup pierre louault on
s'attriste monsieur le commissaire fonds
de compensation du bric site pourquoi la
france fait aussi mal desservies c'est
quand même 4 milliards de 140 millions
alors que les pêcheurs entre autres bons
subir de plein fouet le break site
et puis une question subsidiaire
puisqu'on parle des anglais est-ce que
l'anglais peut reste encore la langue
officielle d'une europe où il n'y a plus
qu'un pour cent des européens qui
parlent l'anglais c'est une sacrée bonne
question
merci pierre et pour terminer martin
berthet du groupe l'est républicain
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le commissaire cher michel à
nouveau bravo et merci pour cet accord
obtenu ma question concerne le secteur
du tourisme et plus particulièrement les
saisonniers britanniques engagées par
les tour operator
en france ces derniers génèrent chaque
année une activité économique non
négligeable
par exemple dans nos stations de ski
mais pas que là s'il semble acquis que
le détachement des personnels leur est
autorisé l'inquiétude et tour opérateurs
et grandes quant au niveau d'acceptation
qui sera donnée aux demandes des permis
de travailler pas pour leurs salariés
ils doivent prendre des engagements dès
maintenant sur le territoire français
pour préparer la saison prochaine et ont
besoin à cet effet de visibilité d'être
rassurés quant à leur possibilité
d'embauché faute de quoi il ne prendrons
pas de risque
aussi monsieur le commissaire des
accords particuliers ont ils été pris
sur ce sujet des permis de travail et
des saisonniers britanniques engagées
dans le secteur du tourisme en europe
afin de faciliter leur traitement et
ainsi conserver l'activité économique
générée merci merci à tous ce
commissaire merci encore dire je rejoins
la question projet a posé j'ai pas
répondu précisément à sa question à la
lumière de la question de cuir lourd sur
le fonds de compensation 400 millions
sur 4 milliards la répartition était
fait sur des bases objectives liées aux
os secteur et aux régions qui sont
potentiellement les plus touchés je
rappelle que nous avons un accord qui
ordonne le bric site c'est pas comme
s'il y avait des tarifs et des quotas
rétablie partout parce que pour le coup
chers collègues on aurait eu des
conséquences extrêmement graves dans le
domaine par exemple nicole de nos
exportations à nous européens et
français vers le royaume uni
les secteurs les plus touchés sont
clairement la pêche puisqu'on sait que
nous devons rendre sur cinq ans et demi
25% passant % et 25 % des opportunités
de pêche
donc il ya des conséquences qui seront
l'objet de ces compensations
on va évaluer les conséquences pour tous
les secteurs mais il ya besoin de d'un
peu de temps quand même c'est pas si
évident que ça
qui aura des conséquences graves partout
je recommande qu'on prenne le temps ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la
commission a proposé de donner une
enveloppe nationale à chaque pays tout
de suite donc les enveloppes sont là et
peuvent être utilisés et les factures
envoyées après si je puis dire hein donc
voila c je recommande que vous gardez le
contact et que les mises des affaires
européennes français le musée la pêche
pour la pêche comme vous le faites pour
vérifier dans quelles conditions et
comment
c'est cet argent est attribué à nos 24e'
noisy a évoqué la non régression
encore une fois je prétends pas que
c'est parfait c'est très compliqué les
britanniques ont fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour une fois qu'ils ont accepté ce
principe d'équivalence dans le temps
mettre des bretelles des ceintures
essayer de le rendre moins opérations de
ces systèmes nous sommes parvenus à un
accord à un compromis
il faudra le juger dans la durée et on a
des moyens dès l'instant où seront
informées la commission sera informée
donc une fois vous avez un rôle à jouer
par les entreprises que vous rencontrez
où les secteurs que vous connaissez ce
et eux-mêmes s'exprimant directement
pour que les outils de répliques de
dissuasion de prévention soit utilisée
mais il y en a un certain nombre est
inclus quand on constatera une
distorsion de concurrence claire pas un
nom de domaine des aides d'état la
capacité de mettre des mesures
compensatoires immédiate
ensuite il y aura le plus à d'arbitrage
qui devra se prononcer mais il y aura
des capacités assez opérationnel de
réagir tout à l'heure c'est toi qui as
pas être contrôle commun de valeurs
n'est pas question mais j'ai pas aimé
j'ai vu la profession mais j'ai pas eu
la pression du mythe de la commission
d'environnement comme l'idée d'instituer
des contrôles communs aux frontières
européennes n'est pas question que ça va
pas mettre des britanniques pour
contrôler nos frontières
donc donc que vous revoir les accords le
dock et s'éteint mais nous avons la
france a créé à peu près 1000 postes de
données supplémentaires pays-bas 700 la
belgique 406 est pas suffisant il en
faudra doser vétérinaire mais on doit
être en mesure de contrôler les nouveaux
flux qui doivent être contrôlées qui ne
l'étaient pas jusqu'au 31 décembre
mais on va pas faire ça en commun avec
les britanniques chercherons pas et je
pense elle catherine que le que la
question de l'initiation européenne est
englobée dans ma réponse tout à l'heure
sur le fait que l'examen de conscience
que je recommande
après le bric citer les leçons de
bauxite s'applique à tout le monde et
inclut administration moi j'ai eu la
chance de trois fois vingt trois paires
de 50 à bruxelles j'ai travaillé avec
des fonctionnaires exceptionnels comme
la rade vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
et beaucoup d'autres et mai à bruxelles
comme partout quand et bureaucrates
prennent le pouvoir c'est que les hommes
politiques ou les femmes politiques leur
laisse le pouvoir
bien sûr c'est pas mal ce que je dis
mais donc il faut que les hommes et
femmes politiques les commissaires sont
des hommes et des femmes politiques et
les ministres des hommes et des femmes
politiques assument la responsabilité et
utilise l'expertisé des fonctionnaires
c'est pas le contraire je puis me
permettre
voilà donc l'examen de conscience sur
l'examen
cette valeur ajoutée vaut pour tout le
monde pierre qu pierse a évoqué la
filière sucre mais ça c'est un problème
je vaux je vois bien les questions de
vases communicants qui peuvent se
produire autre conséquence bilaté deux
acolytes collatéral il faut pas se faire
d'illusions les britanniques vont signer
dans le cadre de leur autonomie ils sont
devenus totalement autonome ils vont
signer les accords commerciaux elle tous
les pays du monde et ils vont apporter
du des agneaux a continué néerlandais
hans tra liens du boeuf brésiliens du
sucre brice bien et je pose qui est le
leur tentation sera de changer au modèle
alimentaire pour être moins dépendants
de notre marché possiblement donc il
faut se préparer
si assez conséquent cela encore une fois
la filière peut faire appel au fonds
d'ajustement pour permettre une
transition je pense à voile un secteur
s'il est directement impacté comme tu
viens de le dire ne peut pas le par le
brésil peut toujours faire appel à ce
fonds via le vient le gouvernement
français donc je il ne fait pas
d'illusions le britannique qui sont
maintenant autonome ils sont concurrents
la question est ce que cette concurrence
reste loyale on a une vigilance mais
cependant la concurrence
elle leur donne le droit de d'apporter
ce qu'ils veulent simplement notre site
va proposer l'appareil d'origine tout à
l'heure c'est très important ce projet
pas répondu mais les rideaux jean c'est
quelque chose qui protège les emplois
chez nous et donc on va appliquer ces
règles rigoureusement on a trouvé des
solutions dans certains domaines comme
le véhicule électrique par exemple mais
les règles s'appliqueront chaîne ou
pourquoi pas ce qu'on veut pas que le
royaume y deviennent à aubes importe de
l'acier ou des pièces du monde entier
ainsi chinois ou japonais ou russe à
bakou - à moindre coût que nous la
portons de l'acier assemble écoles
tampon men in black site même et c'est
la même chose mais made in england et
nous exporte son tarif et sans quota non
on va contrôler sa peau car ils osent
ils doivent s'appliquer parce que
derrière cette question d'un doji il ya
des centaines de milliers d'emplois
augmentent chez nous qu'il faut être
rigoureux
donc nous voilà je je je vous mets mais
il faut changer leur modèle
progressivement je formerai pas trop
d'espoir sur la réouverture des
négociations bilatérales
parce que c'est très compliqué ça veut
dire qu'on remet en cause tous ces
accords on a des accords qui sont
globalement positifs
avec beaucoup de pays dans le monde
qu'on assigne à 28 alors mais je suis
conscient de cette question mais je
pense qu'il ya aussi beaucoup
d'inconvénients réouvrir les
négociations
moi j'ai répondu à pierre louault sur le
fonds de compensation et sur la langue
anglaise
la règle dans l'union européenne c'est
qu'on puisse faire c'est ce que j'ai
fait pendant cinq ans est de prendre en
compte les intérêts de chaque pays et je
vous jure que c'est une des clés de
l'unité 1
donc quand la fin on avait un problème
sur l'aviation les vingt-sept étaient
d'accord quand l'irlande a eu un
problème
les 27 est d'accord quand les pêcheurs
ont eu un problème les 27 ont été
solides avec les huit pays
principalement concernés par la pêche
quant à l'espagne elle m'a posé le
problème de gibraltar les 26 autres ont
été solidaires quand chypre a évoqué la
question des deux bases militaires
britanniques sur chypre on a été
solidaires donc il ya des pays qui
parlent l'anglais hainaut - 2 je vais
pas dire le pourcentage mais l'irlande
et malte
donc on langue anglaise restreint des
langues de l'union je pourrais pas dire
autre chose
voilà j'ai martine martinel une qualité
supplémentaire parmi ou séquelles et
d'albertville voilà qui est ma ville
voilà et alors là la partie c'est une
question compliquée parce que moi j'ai
été vigilant pour que principe tu veux
dire briques site et que s'agissant des
prestataires de services britanniques
ça va pas être la même chose chaque pays
est libre de maintenir les mêmes règles
qu'avant ou pas mais moi j'ai quand même
entendu dans l'ancienne circonscription
qui comprend 23 stations de sports
d'hiver
beaucoup de remarques dans les 15 années
passées sur des prestataires de services
britanniques qui amenait des salariés
britanniques des conditions sociales et
de couvertures sociales différentes et
donc ça sera plus possible
[Musique]